i'm shannon bream i'm tom shailu I'm
Maria Bartiromo and this is the Fox News
rundown
[Music]
Friday March 13th 2020
I'm Lisa Brady no matter what else is
happening the election clock keeps
ticking and for Democrats it means less
and less time to unify behind a nominee
but one thing hasn't changed
I am the prize electability has been the
most important issue to 60 percent plus
of the Democratic electorate from day
one i'm carly Shimkus the controversial
thriller the hunt is now in theaters it
was described as an anti conservative
slasher film the screenwriter explains
how everyone got the movie wrong while
every American independent of what side
of the aisle you stand on or you don't
want to stand in the aisle at all they
all acknowledge that these are divided
times but nobody wants them to be
divided and I'm Charlie Kurt and I've
got the final word on the Fox News
rundown
less than eight months from now voters
across America will be at the polls
choosing a president but first Democrats
have to finish choosing a challenger
whoever it is I hope they make their
choice soon I thought it was gonna be
everybody thought it was gonna be Bernie
president Trump keeps suggesting the
nominations being stolen from senator
Bernie Sanders after an epic comeback by
former Vice President Joe Biden who is
reaching out to Sanders supporters I
believe really an incredible moment in
American history opportunity to deliver
a progressive vision to the American
people but how did Bernie Sanders get to
this point even though his crowds appear
just as enthusiastic about his
democratic socialist revolution as they
were four years ago
the longer Bernie has been on the stage
the more it's been clarified what his
views are and how out of the mainstream
they are and how much of a vulnerability
they might be in a general election Karl
Rove is a Republican strategist and Fox
News contributor I go back to his
comments defending Fidel Castro a couple
weeks ago that was the week before South
Carolina and I think it helped sort of
cause a lot of people to say you know
what he really is way out there in a man
who can't bring himself to denounce
Fidel Castro and excuses and by saying
he had a literacy program it's not a guy
feel comfortable with and you couple
that with the South Carolina win which
was largely due to Clyburn endorsement
and the strong support that Biden had in
the african-american community and and
that that had a lethal combination going
into Super Tuesday of causing a lot of
people to say you know what I've now
become convinced that Bernie would be a
disaster I've seen a lot of TV ads but
haven't become convinced that Bloomberg
is the alternative and Mayor Pete and
Amy don't seem to have the gravitas
necessary to be President I guess I'm
going with Biden sometimes in politics
it's better to be lucky than good and
Biden was very lucky I've never seen 72
hours like we saw from the end of the
South Carolina primary through the end
of Super Tuesday hasn't Sanders at least
succeeded though in pushing
the party to embrace some of his
progressive ideas because some things
from four years ago are suddenly being
you know talked about a lot more now oh
absolutely absolutely look his goal is
to transform the Democratic Party and
then transform the country he's a
revolutionary and he has a he wants to
commit the Democratic Party to a
socialist agenda which is why I think
he's going to stay in he understands not
a conventional politician he's not
trying to curry favor he's not a good
you know these are not his friends this
is not get along go along I owe these
people something it is I fought them
every step of the way from the time and
I ran for mayor Congress governor u.s.
senator I've always had to fight a
Democrat in order to get elected and I'm
only using my candidacy as a way to
transform the Democratic Party and
transform the country so yeah I think
he's been very successful I thought it
was interesting though that Bernie
Sanders in those first public remarks
after his heavy losses Tuesday
essentially offered what almost sounded
like a cheat sheet for Joe Biden for an
upcoming debate saying yes I'm going to
ask you about this and this and this and
he went into fairly great detail could
that also have been a way to say to
Biden here's what you need to address
from my supporters to be able to vote
for you if it comes to that oh
absolutely absolutely I mean he you know
look he would he drew more attention to
debate by doing that he made clear the
big differences potentially between the
two of them and he put himself in a
position where if I had agreed with him
he looked like Biden was making a
concession all of those strengths and
Bernie they may not strengthen him in
the ability to win delegates but they
strengthen his influence over the party
in the you know we can show up in in in
July and say well in the debate in
Arizona you promised this you promised
that let's ride it into the platform and
thereby binds the Democratic Party to
more of his views at this point the math
to win the nomination is not on Sanders
side jessica Tarlov is a Democratic
strategist and Fox News contributor when
you look
at the states that are in play Bernie's
best shot of making some headway was
last Tuesday and the mini Super Tuesday
he should have picked up Washington he
should have picked up Idaho but if
you're looking at Florida and Georgia
and Arizona these are states where Biden
has a huge lead and it just continues to
grow is there any kind of reasoning that
makes sense for the Sanders campaign
from the standpoint of look the longer
we stay in however the more we can
encourage the party to embrace our
progressive ideas and maybe get it into
the platform come convention time well
that's a theory of the case that they
had in 2016 and they accomplished a lot
of it I mean they push the party to the
left certainly on health care was
probably their biggest achievement on
issues like in the Middle East
actually they were able to push the
party to the last kind of a way from I
would say I'm not like a unilaterally
pro-israel stance but certainly with
more concessions for how we were going
to handle the two-state solution so yeah
that's an argument to make though I
would say that Bernie Sanders his impact
has already been felt in the way that
people ran this race and in how someone
like Elizabeth Warren crafted their
entire campaign so I'm not sure actually
how much he's going to accomplish that
way I just think that timing wise it was
too early for his energized base which
is smaller then he said it was and we
have to keep that in mind he did not
deliver the record turnout that he had
promised us but if it looks like he is
just giving up before we at least get
through the March 17th primaries I think
that he would be facing a lot more anger
from his base than he wants to take on
so I think it's less of a negotiation
and more of a just follow through until
the delegate math is so clear that it's
an impossibility and then to make the
case to his supporters that we have to
unify to beat Trump in November is it in
the voters hands and I mean that from
the standpoint of do the Democratic
voters at this point have the ability to
get behind Biden enough to end this
primary fight earlier than it ended
years ago I
so I mean there so there are two key
factors that I'm paying attention to
that we've seen so turnout is bonkers
I trust in someplace like in Virginia
that had doubled is absurd right so
that's going on and that's something
that Biden talked about where he said I
can turnout people that you are not
thinking of everyone made fun of him for
saying we should be doing outreach to
conservative Democrats independents who
are right leaning and moderate
Republicans there are a lot of Romney
Republicans sitting around that are
horrified at what's going on right now
and we can reach them so that's one
element the other element is how much of
2016 was not about Bernie Sanders but
about how much people hated Hillary
Clinton and I don't know if you've had a
chance to watch the Hulu documentary yet
about her but it's very clear from the
conversations that they're having that
they were aware of the fact that there
was an unprecedented smear campaign
against her for decades right that goes
back obviously to whitewater I mean her
whole basically since she met Bill
Clinton Hillary Clinton has been
lampooned and Sanders won a lot of
primaries in 2016 not because of him but
because people weren't enamored with
Hillary so they just didn't show up for
it
iDEN doesn't have that problem people
are more comfortable with him I think it
matters that he's a dude and that she
was obviously not a dude and sexism is a
factor in our elections and I guess for
Democrats is probably also not even a
bad thing if the vote for Biden isn't so
much against Bernie Sanders but against
President Trump exactly that's how every
democratic vote I believe finish our
election will be cast
I mean Biden has an enthusiastic
african-american base which people who
were dismissing it when the numbers got
a little wonky was very upsetting to me
because it was it was quite clear that
this was the only person in the race
that our most reliable voting bloc felt
connected to and had known for decades
and decades and decades and obviously
Jim Clyburn really swung it over the
edge when he came out with that very
moving endorsement of him but eye on the
prize electability has been the most
important issue to 60 percent plus of
the Democratic electorate from day one
they see Trump as an existential threat
to the nation and I mean who
knock on wood that kovat 19 is under
control at some point soon but I don't
think it's going to be and the economy
now is completely wonky that was what
Trump could run on and I thought that he
would win on it looks a lot more in
doubt that you're gonna be able to
successfully run on an economy that
looks like this and if Biden is the
nominee Karl Rove acknowledges he won't
be as easy a target for the president as
Bernie Sanders they've got to make sure
that people understand how the you know
the depths that he's taken to the left
it's not not going to be just enough to
attach a you know a label to him sleepy
Joe or whatever but it's going to have
to be you know they're gonna have to go
after his agenda and what he has said
and their you know for example saying
that you know you're gonna ban drilling
on federal lands in federal waters I
mean that's gonna hurt them in places
like Texas and Louisiana which the
Democrats may have thrown away but it's
also going to hurt them in places like
New Mexico and Colorado which are up for
grabs perhaps in this environment if
this if the case can be made but you
know I'm free healthcare for illegal
aliens that that's gonna be unpopular in
a lot of places you were with President
Bush during 9/11 in terms of responding
to a crisis how do you handle it what do
you do since we're in the midst of this
coronavirus situation now first of all
the president has to be surrounded by
strong people who are capable of of
helping him make the right decisions
that is to say identified decisions that
have to be made and given the president
the best arguments on both sides of the
case and let him make the call the
president needs to have somebody who is
designated to run the day-to-day of the
process to make sure that the entire
government is moving as one that it was
a very smart move to provide to pick a
vice president Mike Pence at that and
allow him to provide that kind of
leadership I thought very important the
president has important role in making
decisions but there's got to be somebody
who's paying attention to the
nitty-gritty and helping identify the
issues that need to be fully staffed out
and taken to the president for his
decision president has a big microphone
a big megaphone to talk to the American
people he used on the span of travel of
European visitors there going to be
other moments like that which
he needs a good speech writing staff and
that stand and the communication shop
needs to be able to explain that policy
fill in the detail and third of all the
president needs to in situations like
this to defer to the experts
if campaigning at least in the short
term becomes less and less personal if
they have to have less interaction on
the trail holding virtual events for
instance how much could that impact the
outcome because the president's known
for his big rallies Joe Biden for
instance is known as being a hugger not
just a handshake er could this really
impact the race
yes but realize this we do have in just
under 8 months until the election but
there's plenty of time for rallies I
mean the president is the president and
i think george w bush's first event i
mean we might have had one or two events
in the spring of 2004 but we were really
not active in sort of campaign mode
until june so he's got plenty of time as
the incumbent a guy who's going to be
sort of crimped for this right now is
biden because it's going to be things
like debates and it's going to be things
like election outcomes but in between
it's going to be hard for him to do
things that sort of grab people's
attention when we're all talking about
the coronavirus republican strategists
and Fox News contributor Karl Rove
thanks so much for your time you bet
thank you
[Music]
this is Charlie Kirk with your Fox News
commentary
coming up last summer a violent movie
called the hunt sparked widespread
political backlash it slashed its way
onto the scene in July and while no one
had seen it yet the trailer in a
shocking Hollywood Reporter piece about
it led folks to believe it's about rich
liberals hunting down and killing Trump
supporters for fun every year a bunch of
elites kidnap where they get you from
the outrage in headlines were instant
many felt the movie was twisted and
dangerous then in August a real-life
horror took place
second or two was happening to mass
shootings one in Dayton Ohio the other
in El Paso Texas a few days later the
president tweeted that the movie was
created in order to inflame and cause
chaos Universal Pictures responded by
canceling its September release date
indefinitely six months later it was
announced that it would hit theaters
after all in you can see it now
the film's new tagline the most talked
about movie of the year is one no one
has seen yet so is this movie really a
gory political horror about eliminating
Magga supporters it was less about
wanting to play off or exploit the
political division in the country and
more just sort of reflect a certain
degree of absurdity about it Damon
Lindelof co-wrote the film he also
co-created lost in HBO's the leftovers
he says the movie was actually created
to mock the nation's political divide
and help bring people back together I
will say this and maybe I'm just too
glass half-full or too optimistic but I
do think that while every American
independent of what side of the aisle
you stand on or you don't want to stand
in the aisle at all they all acknowledge
that these are divided times but nobody
wants them to be divided and so I think
that the idea of the movie was to do
like a our intention at least was to
present a very absurdist extreme to say
like this is not where we are but it's
where we're headed and it's an
opportunity to maybe laugh at ourselves
a bit that's the hardest thing for me to
do as a storyteller is to kind of you
know make fun of myself and and the
bubble that I'm in and the movie is sort
of an expression yeah you know you you
sort of say that this movie is a
cautionary tale like how ridiculous is
it that people are actually hurting
people because of their political
disagreements but some people saw the
trailer last year and thought that the
movie was dangerous and I think a lot of
people were upset because of the simple
fact that it's about a certain political
party the conservative political party
getting murdered because of their
beliefs what is your response to that
criticism I think it's a legitimate
criticism
and I completely understand why that was
the takeaway from the trailer my hope is
that yet if people choose to go see the
movie they'll understand that that's not
really what it's about and I I think
it's more about it's not about their
being murdered for their political
beliefs their being murdered for
assumptions about what their political
beliefs are one of the things about the
movie is nobody tries to engage anyone
else in an actual conversation or a
spirited debate of ideas they just sort
of leap right to this sort of extreme
viewpoint and I think that this idea
that you look at someone and and based
on the state that they live in or the
way that they talk or the way that they
dress or the job that they have you make
all these automatic assumptions about
you know something very personal and in
many in many ways more complicated than
just saying I am a conservative or I am
a liberal there's a lot of nuance in
people's political beliefs but at the
end of the day even people that we love
in our own family may not share our
political beliefs but the solution is
not to exact violence applause yeah hate
grows when you don't even try to talk to
the other side or somebody different and
I think that this movie sort of captures
captures that feeling very well
back in August President Trump posted a
tweet criticizing the movie saying it
was created to inflame and caused chaos
obviously you disagree with that
perspective but what was it like to see
the president tweet something negative
about the movie and what would you tell
him about what you've created and why he
was wrong it was it was obviously a very
surreal experience and not something
that I ever imagined would happen to be
in my lifetime for the president United
States to to be aware of the movie let
alone tweet about it and I guess my
feeling at the time that had happened
was
it was sort of following this this in
entire week after these horrific
shootings and in El Paso and Dayton
which I think the entire country was
collectively reeling about and I think
that the movie got caught up in that
swirl understandably because of because
of the idea that it was a it was a
violent movie and had sort of political
undertones and I guess all I would say
is that I'm relieved that the
conversation is now shifting into what
the movie is
versus what people thought the movie was
and I all I can say is for anyone who
knows me or my co-writer Nick or the or
the director Craig or even jason blum
who obviously has made a lot of these
kind of crazy horror movies and and even
been nominated for Oscars and all sorts
of things is nobody wants nobody
nobody's intention was to make something
dangerous the last thing that this
country needs is a movie that is like is
making us feel yucky or were inciting
some level of violence I think that the
purpose of the movie was to show an
extreme and actually you know get us to
starts to take a step back away from the
edge of the cliff versus jumping over it
you know I was lucky enough to be able
to see the movie in advance and I think
that you know you did a very good job of
sort of making creating these ridiculous
stereotypes about both liberals and
conservatives but what am i take away so
as I sort of think that you the movie
comes down harder on the liberal
characters than it does conservatives
have you heard that before you know
that's a really interesting perspective
and I haven't heard a phrase quite that
way I will say I you know my my friends
in the bubble with me who have seen the
movie are sort of like ooh that stings a
little was that supposed to sting and I
think like what I would say is that for
me I'm much more comfortable making fun
of myself than I am making fun of others
and so the world that I travel in the
people that I know you know it's much
easier to write a satire about them and
so I think that if the movie is you know
we were we were searching for for people
to walk out of it feeling like it was as
balanced as humanly possible but give
given my own you know sort of like
affiliation predisposition again I don't
want to oversimplify it by saying this
is what I am but it's on the progressive
I'm much more comfortable taking shots
at myself than I am at anyone yeah well
the stereotypes are you know they're all
funny and if you can't laugh at yourself
it's and who can you laugh at are you
nervous that this movie won't be
well-received by
conservatives liberals or people who
maybe just don't like violence if the
conversation around the movie just
basically moves into a space of is it
good or is it bad right it I like it or
did is it funny is it not funny
that will be a huge relief to me yeah
for the people who have seen the movie
no one has said to me oh I think this
movie is dangerous in fact if there's
the most primary negative reaction that
I've gotten so far is that some people
were expecting it to be really
controversial and provocative and they
seemed a little bit disappointed when
they see that it's just a fun kind of
b-movie where you know people are
running around and and shooting at each
other and I understand that if you know
you describe the movie to people it
feels like it's provocative but I think
everyone who's actually seen it is kind
of like oh hi was it was a bit of much
ado about that yeah after the satire is
definitely a more on full display and in
the movie then it wasn't in the original
trailer and after I thought I couldn't
stop thinking about it so that bodes
well for I think what you want people to
take out of the movie but you bring up
an interesting point about you know
violence in movies and all that and when
the Joker came out a lot of people said
that it would it could inspire a
real-world violence do you think that
filmmakers and screenwriters have a
responsibility to take that into
consideration absolutely you have to
have that conversation I mean when you
say take it into consideration 100
percent and then the question just
becomes do you proceed anyway my belief
whether it's right or wrong is I just
have a tremendous amount of state and
the audience I think you can't treat the
American audience or the world's I
audience like their children people make
a choice as to whether or not they want
to go see a movie if you see a trailer
for Joker and it looks violent and
upsetting for you then you shouldn't go
see the Joker and people can sort of
self-select
we're not forcing anybody to watch any
of this stuff but I think that it is
irresponsible to just make something
that is exploitative or it's
purposefully divisive or it's glorifying
you know violent themes and ideas like
you have to have the conversation of
what am I trying to say here like is
there is there a way that I could be
misunderstood
do you help people walk away with after
they've seen this movie if anything we
wanted to reflect the absurdity of as
you said stereotypes you know if there's
any message from the movie it is the old
standby of don't judge a book by it's
cover you know don't make judgments
about someone just based on on how they
look or how they talk or where they
where they're from I think that people
are much more complicated than that and
look we we love our families but but
this idea of sort of like selecting a
team and being on that team and that
kind of gets you nowhere and we'd much
rather you know sit at the Thanksgiving
table and have a spirited conversation
then not go to the Thanksgiving table at
all yeah so well said and something this
country definitely needs to remember and
reflect on at a time like this well this
movie is unabashedly violent there are a
lot of creative murders and considering
you're the co-writer how did you come up
with them what part of your brain did
you tap into and should we be concerned
about you look I think that um that most
children and certainly most of the young
boys that I was hanging out with when I
was six and seven years old found
inventive ways to dismember our action
figures we would tie firecrackers to
them we were to rip them in half we
would just you know drop them and you
know to a you know
pits of mud etcetera etcetera and so I
think that you know it sort of starts
there and obviously these are these are
people and in a movie but I think that
Nick and I and certainly Craig wanted to
go as over-the-top as humanly possible
in depicting this violence and and the
idea that there it's almost so absurd
and silly when someone is basically you
know falling into a pit full of sharp
spikes and their entire body has been
torn in half yeah and they're still
talking and won and talking about
birthday cake you know that hopefully
the audience is like okay they are not
and we're not meant to take this to see
yeah
well I will never look at a high-heeled
shoe the same way and trust me I own a
lot of them definitely tear they're very
you're both here yeah yeah David thank
you so much for talking to me and I
appreciate it good luck on your
open-mindedness
[Music]
if you are enjoying the Fox News rundown
you can listen every day by going to Fox
News podcasts dot-com and subscribing
there you'll also find exclusive podcast
hosted by some of your favorite Fox News
personalities including Deena Perino
Bret Baier Martha McCallum and Greg
Gutfeld head over to Fox News podcasts
dot-com to listen and subscribe on your
favorite podcast platform and now some
good news with Tanya Jay powers
technology is helping Bruce the goose
live his best life 13-year old Bruce as
a domestic Chinese goose who was injured
by a raccoon and almost lost his life
he's a feisty one has a lot of attitude
and opinions but he loves people
Susan Curtis is the director of the
nonprofit Sandy's Haven which is a
sanctuary for wildlife in farm animals
she says the fight left Bruce with no
bill which is bad their mouths will dry
out their tongue gets very dry and
uncomfortable they can't eat as well
they can't drink they can't take care of
themselves they can't defend themselves
so they 3d printed him a new one
sanctuary manager Jodi Curtis says they
tried several prototypes before they
found a bill that worked we have used a
glue that's it's used in dentistry for
placing crowns in place
Carmen Ramirez was part of the team that
made the bill first he shook his head
like rejecting it but then he started
moving his mouth up and down like
starting to use the beak and it was
really cool Jodi says it can also make a
difference not just for Bruce but to
others as well one thing we really enjoy
is taking these animals into places like
assisted living or hospitals things like
that where people can see how their
lives are turning out and the pleasure
that they can bring and it just helps
their lives immensely
Bruce has a new lease on life as
expected to live two or three more years
Tonya joy powers Fox News
[Music]
it's time for your Fox News commentary
Charlie Kurt what's on your mind
no man has completely controlled
American politics the way President
Donald J Trump has not Reagan not
Roosevelt not even Lincoln no national
news story is complete without including
his most recent comments no policy is
worth discussing unless we know what
Trump has to say about it
the Democrats don't seem to know what
they stand for
unless it's socialism or the opposite of
whatever Trump says many Republican
officeholders aren't much better far too
many have spent so much time away from
their constituents they don't know
they're on the wrong side of an issue
until they hear Trump speak their
constant grasping at illogical policies
betrays an underlying truth about
President Trump that none of his critics
on either side of the aisle want to
admit he is not simply shooting from the
hip or governing on a whim they are he
has a clearly defined framework and
basis for his decisions upon that system
they are the ones who have no definable
playbook to counter his moves that often
seem two steps ahead if you're a trump
supporter when I'm about to lay out
should be a clear statement of what
you've known all along but maybe
struggled to put into words
first he believes in American
sovereignty he will always side with
American citizens over those from other
countries second he will always stand up
for everyday working Americans over the
quote elites those who love their
families and their God those who are
doing things the right way
those who shower before and after work
no matter how deranged his detractors
get this is a simple moral stance I am
proud to get behind we were told that
nothing could be done to reverse the
devastating toll the last few decades
have taken on American workers
we were told we can never protect the
needs of the men and women punching the
clock in middle America against the
overwhelming forces of globalization
Trump rejected this conventional wisdom
pushed by the ruling class in Washington
he defied the quote experts and was
adamant
we could turn things around he was
writes this brand of positive
conservative populism is not bigoted or
mean-spirited it's common sense but the
left has no way to comprehend the magum
moment were in because they're no longer
grateful to live in America they don't
want to make it great again they want to
quote fundamentally transform it I write
in my new book the mag a doctrine that
unlike the left the president deeply
loves America and holds dear the values
that made this the greatest country in
the history of the world he sided with
those who's been chewed up by a
government prone to political
correctness high taxes the enrichment of
our trading partners at our expense and
appeasement of our greatest geopolitical
foes like Iran and China many of these
individuals are tired of seeing the
government sympathized with not
Americans over them they're tired of the
Democrats saying there's no way to quote
wave a magic wand to restore our
economic might sometimes the left
insults the president by saying he's
playing checkers not chess the irony is
that he keeps beating all of his
adversaries at whatever game they want
to play if we can properly understand
the lessons he's taught us we can make
sure that the Trump moment becomes the
Trump movement one that helps
conservatives win for generations to
come
I'm charlie Kirk author of the book
Magadh doctrine the only ideas that will
win the future
now available
you have been listening to the FoxNews
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
the Fox News radios hourly newscast at
FoxNews podcasts dot-com and for
up-to-the-minute news visit Fox news.com
[Music]
love FoxNews click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the FoxNews rundown
playlist for the latest episodes